In Turkey, officials recover 24 bodies...
...after a boat believed to be carrying illegal migrants sank off the coast of Istanbul.
In India and Pakistan, funerals are held for family members killed in a suicide attack...
...that left more than 55 dead and hundreds wounded.
In Ukraine, pro-Russian separatist Alexander Zakharchenko...
...was declared the winner in the rebel elections...
...while Kiev and the West denounce the vote.
In Syria, Islamic State militants claim they now control a gas field...
...in the central province of Homs.
This is the second gas field seized in a week.
And finally from Romania, the presidential election is going to a runoff vote...
...after no candidate earned a majority in Sunday's first round.